Ma'am. All right.
You go.
Please remove that woman.
Police officer, please.
You removed your breaching protocol
and disorder in the committee room.
You took my son away from me,
and I'm not going anywhere.
I want to listen to your son now.
Yeah. Is it?
Why don't you remote wrestling original
to an honorary degree in this area for
the committee.
Welcomes the public to this meeting.
We have people on both sides
of the aisle.
We have people on
both sides of the aisle.
We are supposed to be one of the 1300
more listeners.
Have the right to.
What about watching the press?
It is not.
But he's not.
He's not violent.
Those are the parents of Parkland
shooting victim
walking Oliver at a congressional hearing
on gun rights today.
Capitol Police,
as you could see,
pinned Joaquin's father, Manuel
Oliver, to the ground and arrested him
outside of the hearing room
while his wife and a crowd looked on.
Manuel and Patricia Oliver join me now.
They're also the co-founders of the gun
safety nonprofit Change the Ref.
Guys, thank you so much for being here.
Manuel, what was happening there?
What were we seeing?
Well,
you see me getting arrested and.
But more than that is that we
we were seeing how how these side of the
hearing was just
telling us lie after lie after lie.
I think that the story
is not about me getting arrested.
It's more about Patricia representing
all mothers
that have sought
for the losing their son or daughter.
She was right there
putting in her voice very loud.
So these liars will know where we are
and what we stand for.
We lost our son,
and that should be addressed in some way.
Patricia, what was it
that you were hoping to accomplish?
What were the lies?
Were you trying to combat
some information?
What were you trying to do
in that hearing room?
Really, what I was trying to do in
the hearing room is to listen to that.
So we were just
they were just discussing
about remove the ATF office
because they don't consider
that this is an office
that we have to be working on
doing something
that is really needed today,
which is gun violence
that is happening
every single moment of the day.
Every day.
And when I was listening to them
over and over,
going through issues
that they were and related
to the main reason
we were on the hearing, I just lost it.
And I got to say to the speaker,
to the leader speaker there that
I lost my son because of them,
because they wait to see them.
The view that they have about gun
violence is totally different.
It's away from reality.
Hmm.
Manuel, they say that you were being
you were both being disruptive,
and you know, that
that that can't stand
in the hearing room.
Was there a better way
to have a discussion with lawmakers?
Well, you know what?
I'm I'm ready to have a discussion
at any time.
I was in there
plotting to do this
like someone called me Nas,
who says today,
I'm not enjoying in these.
I mean,
some of these guys were moving
from one room to the other
while they were debating that.
The danger is
actually is that
the ATF has an ongoing ownership
and the Second Amendment.
And we're also debating about
banning Tik Tok
because it damages our kids brains.
I do have to remind people
that the autopsy of my son
revealed that his brain exploded.
They found pieces of Keane's
brain around Joaquin's body.
So no one is banning
assault weapons as of today.
The reason that why we were
there was to represent all parents.
We we're not planning to do this,
but I will not tolerate
any more lies from these people.
And I really hope
that people will realize
that they have to get involved.
Like we got involved
at one point, the chairman one
the chairman of this, Pat Fallon,
likened the outburst to January 6th.
So let me just play you that exchange.
Is this an insurrection?
So will they be held to the same?
I don't want another January six, do we?
If they're trying
to overthrow the government,
they ought to be
held to the same standard.
But I think they're trying
to express them.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Members out of line.
Does the Capitol Police
not do their jobs?
What the hell's going on?
What are your thoughts on that?
Well, this guy is making a joke
about this. Really?
The chairman in this session
is joking about
what's happening,
comparing what I did
with the insurrection.
Honestly, you're doing that,
showing the whole country
what your opinion is,
how your how your thoughts,
your process of thinking works.
Shame on you.
That's what I think.
Patricia, it's very cynical.
I was outside.
Meanwhile, they were arresting Manuel,
and I was just saying
to the security guys
that they were very rude at that point,
that we were
just using our First Amendment.
And that's what I did
when I was inside the room.
I was the one who would stand up and say
what I said to to the Speaker.
I don't want to even say his name either.
He's not worth to be, name it.
And I think that they just act
the way they are acting
because they want to grab attention
and that's so bad.
So we are playing here
to get attention in any at any price.
So why you don't do your job
and say what you have to do,
you have to say
and move forward
with the life that we need to get done.
Instead of being complaining
about
and joking
about what happened on January 6th
that was very sick and everybody is still
working on that
and punished people because of that.
Yeah.
Well,
we know that you two are still fighting
for this cause
and that you're still trying to act
as your son Joaquin's voice.
And we really appreciate you being here
and sharing what happened today with us.
Thank you.
Thank you, Terry. Take care.
You, too.
I'll be right back with my panel.